Adam Adam Adam
the man the myth The Legend and today I
thought maybe I've talked about Adam a
little too much I mean all he did was
call me a misogynist
you know that's it it's not like I need
to cover him all week
until I looked up the definition of
misogyny
and it is the hatred of women
can you believe that he thinks that I
hate women
hate is such a strong term
I think you hate children if you're
putting your kids
online
in a sexual manner which we covered last
time but you know call me old-fashioned
I don't know maybe that's too crazy
whatever
so I will continue to cover this so Adam
basically let his wife get railed by
another dude and what we see here is
this egalitarian model
I want to get the best the hottest chick
I can the best in bed whatever and
therefore to compete
and to pass on my genes I'm gonna let
her get railed by other dudes and just
turn that off in me I'm just gonna
silence that hind brain that's saying
wow
I really don't want to watch
my girl get banged by other dudes
so not only did he decide to do that he
also decided to reward his wife for
doing this porn scene pull up the clip
King I'm so proud of you doing your
first ever BBC scene that I decided that
I wanted to get you a little something
nice open your eyes what this
me
either this is for you anything for my
queen
I love it thank you
so not only not only did he let his wife
get railed by another dude
he also is giving her a car because of
it
you know honestly if that was the reward
for Cheating in relationships I know a
lot of [__] out there deserve cars
sorry okay look it look it
I don't know why
they would do this it's like it's almost
like they're like possessed by something
like can you just imagine I keep
thinking I don't really give a [__] what
people do in their relationships
but when a magic growing up
and this is your dad you remember like
growing up you would talk to your dad
he'd like teach you how to do something
like my dad he would like drive me to
and from basketball games he would help
help coach my basketball team really the
best guy on the entire planet my dad and
on the way to and from
we would just have talks about like life
his childhood he'd give me like life
lessons whatever
now imagine if your dad was on social
media talking about how he lets his wife
get pimped out by other dudes now to be
fair
a lot of guys out there are getting
pimped out by other dudes and they just
don't know it
okay right like let's let's just call
what it is but it's like a different
level of evil when you become proud of
something and you start to like put it
in the public eye with no regard for how
your kids feel
and it's really interesting because we
all know that you didn't really know
what was going on below the age of like
12 13 right like I mean what do you
really remember everything's kind of
blurry but there's something sacred
about protecting the innocence of
children
and there is no way that you can live
your life like this and your child is
going to be protected from all of this
craziness until they're old enough
there's just no way we live in a social
media Society somebody is going to say
something
and as a parent it's your job to put the
kids first it's your job to protect the
children
um and it's really sad that not only are
they not protecting the kid
they're celebrating this so you know
maybe you would think that
Adam was like all right I got this sex
scene out of the way we're done
um and now
I have moved on from this time in my
life and he sort of did right let's
let's pull the next update on the story
and I'm gonna tell you one last thing
before I get off this is that if my next
child comes out African-American I'm
gonna love him or her and raise them
like my own because that's how woke I am
brother
it do hit different when your child's
gonna come out black ass we don't know
how it's gonna go have a big ass nose
and hit different hey hey hey it's
different
so let me let me get this straight let
me get this straight he
is going to raise the child if it's not
his
and this is the thing this is what we've
conditioned and programmed men to do so
first it's like a slippery slope okay
like a hundred years ago they're like
look women in around the 1920s women
moved out of their apartment so it used
to be before around the Roaring Twenties
women would go from their dad's house to
their husband's house there would be no
living on their own no having their own
place
in around the 20s that was when women
started to work and they started to
have an apartment in between their dad
and their husband's house and that's
when you see promiscuity Rising so it
was kind of a slippery slope for the men
with telling them what to accept so in
the beginning they say all right guys
um you really you need to accept
non-virgins the women they're not
virgins anymore a hundred years ago 85
percent of women were virgins today 95
are not on their wedding day so first
they said men
accept the non-virgins then they slipped
it in a little bit more they they put in
this propaganda right and they put in
all this propaganda telling women they
needed to work telling women they should
go out in the workforce and earn their
own money so they put all this
programming into the med okay now you
have no authority over your household
now you guys are equal partnership happy
wife happy life they just subtly started
telling men okay except except now she's
not a virgin and now you don't even get
Authority in your own house it's equal
equality egalitarianism
okay so the men are like okay
but then the women keep going further so
not only they're like okay maybe she
slept with her High School boyfriend
now it's like I have guys saying please
less than 10 dudes can you guys think
about how crazy that is
it used to be virginity was the standard
for marriage that now it's like okay I
hope she slept with less than 10 guys
five would be amazing like this is the
this is what I'm hearing from the guys
okay so now they're accepting a ton of
dudes right basically so now now they're
accepting [__] wives
and now we're to the point they're
they're bringing the whoredom into
marriage so it used to be okay
you have to accept that she had a crazy
life before you
now they say okay
she should not have to put away the
Crazy Life After you and now they are
trying to have men be an open
relationships with women now I know a
lot of you will say well but Adam had an
open relationship too like Lena let him
sleep with all these women or it's not
that complicated
I'm really tired of this acting like
we're the same women sleep around for
love women sleep for love men sleep
around for sex that's it and you know
you could argue that maybe some women
condition themselves so much so that
they're like numb or they feel nothing
but all in all women get attached
through sex men really don't it's it is
not the same we are not the same so a
woman cheating in a marriage is
infinitely worse than a man cheating in
a marriage I said it it's worse ladies
we are not the same stop resenting men
because we are not the same as them it
doesn't matter how much you shame them
into being the same it doesn't matter
how much you make them believe that
we're the same it doesn't matter how
much you try to convince the world that
we're the same we're not
and typically
this is wisdom that was passed on from
our grandparents our great grandmas to
us tip one we have a generation of women
that were never submissive wives and the
generation before that we think we know
better than
that's why I swear when half of the
ladies half of these women from between
30 and 50 years old roughly they're not
good wives they've never been submissive
in their life and they don't believe in
obeying their husband and they
constantly berate their husbands 24 7.
so I'm telling you the quality of wives
out there it's it's very few but my
whole my whole point is now they're
trying to sell to you that you can have
an open relationship in marriage and I
honestly I think this is disrespectful
to people that actually believe in
marriage I really think it is I think
some people are not qualified for
marriage yes I think if you want to
sleep with other people if you want to
pimp out your wife
maybe did long-term relationship game is
for you especially as a woman because
cheating is not the same for men and for
women sorry guys
next after this whole thing happened
Adam decided to call out Jason
you know I I thought maybe at some point
Adam would be like you know this is a
bit much let's see what Adam had to say
I guess we're uh doing this today hey
Jason love I trusted you to Pork my life
it seems like that clout is getting to
your head I'm talking real real spicy
and I ain't really feeling it number one
the angle of the dangle is more
important than the cubic of the pubic
that's number one number two my d game
when I'm serving it man it's just like
your mom's home cooking because there's
a special ingredient
you ever heard of it number three don't
make me expose you and you know what I'm
talking about it could get real real
messy out here number four you don't
want problems moving around in these La
streets cause I can make that happen I'm
very very well connected number five you
are officially blacklisted
smashing my wife again
mistake
I mean I guess he technically
blacklisted him from screwing his wife
it doesn't really sound serious this
kind of
I mean I'm with the jokes I'm a jokester
too so it doesn't this doesn't sound
like does he sound intimidating are you
intimidated I
like and what what could you expose a
porn star for
I mean like this is like bottom of the
barrel like what what could you expose a
porn star for I
you know I guess I guess good for him
for blacklisting him from screwing your
wife
um
I don't know what on Earth is this
planet anyways in other news Bebe rexha
um she is an American singer now
honestly I don't really know or care
about her music I think she had some
songs I maybe listened to in college I
don't know but this woman broke up with
her boyfriend now
maybe it was for a good reason right I
mean let's let's stop always taking the
men's side Sometimes women dump their
boyfriends for good reasons and there
are good women out there that really
have real reasons for dumping their
boyfriends okay there's abusers that I
always hear about there's all these
emotionally manipulative toxic
narcissists that I just I hear about all
the time so maybe he was just the worst
boyfriend ever let's Tune In singer Bebe
Rex says publicly dumped her boyfriend
after expressed concern over her 35
pound weight gain and changing facial
features do you agree with Bibi for
dumping her boyfriend
or for expressing concern can you show
what she looked like before this is a
classic case of
what I signed up for
versus what I now have all right so
right there she starts off looking like
that
okay you know she gains like 10 15 but
the guys will put up with that but
now she's starting to get pretty fat
I think that's more does that look like
25 pounds to you that looks more like 30
to 50 to me
I think that was downplayed but let's
let's read the text that he sent the
toxic
narcissistic abusive text okay it's
funny because all these women leaking
texts really are just publicly posting
their L's
so her boyfriend said ex-boyfriend now
hey I never said you weren't beautiful
and I never said I didn't love you in
fact I said how beautiful you are and
how much I loved you but I'll always
have said that I would want to be honest
with you your and your face was changing
so I told you what it was this was the
conversation we are having and you ask
because I care would you rather I lie to
you you gained 35 pounds obviously you
gained weight and your face changes
should I just pretend it didn't happen
and that it's okay come on I gained
three pounds and you call me chubs and
fat doesn't mean you don't love me if
you're trying to find reasons to break
this up this makes sense but this is not
a real reason if you're unhappy with me
or yourself about life and don't see a
future with us then that's okay if
that's the reason don't use something
like this to weaponize your anger or
anxiety or money insecurity that you may
have you know I have always found you to
be beautiful and love you no matter what
I think it's important for you to think
about things and write things down speak
to a therapist and do the repeat thing
to get to the root of the problem let me
know if you need to speak let me know if
you'd like to speak if you need more
clarity one I will tell you his one
mistake sending her to a therapist
because the therapist will just call him
an abuser a narcissist Guys these
therapists they do not have your best
interests at heart I know there's
exceptions but they put all of the
feminist propaganda in the schools
to teach these therapists trust me I
went to school for psychology these
women you do not want giving you any
advice about anything and when you think
about it they've really outsourced
family because you really aren't
supposed to need to tell a stranger your
problems and get feedback you're
supposed to get feedback from your
family so these therapists just let the
women think that the men are crazy and
do nothing wrong and at the end of the
day I really would prefer a guy that
would tell me if I got fat I liked it as
women like do we really want a guy that
never tells us when we do wrong like the
guys should and this is the thing and we
should appreciate that from men because
we get out of pocket we get all
emotional our hormones start to go and
honestly we should appreciate from guys
when they give us feedback because they
have a more logical view on the world
let's look at the comments let's see if
the women the married women give give
such good advice in our amazing wives
looks like this young man learned a
valuable lesson a brick house turns into
a big house
at least she dumped him and made it
easier for him to move on and find
someone that reflects his values see
everyone's taking his side it's really
none of my business but he seems like a
gentleman to me from what I read he just
wants her to be healthy yeah he's
probably gonna get Hella DMS from this
she's like she doesn't know what she's
doing because a lot of times they'll
post it and then all the girls are like
that sounds like a good boyfriend
they'll just DM him uh the boyfriend
should have dumped her for being obese
okay now the girl says now the women so
that's from the men now the women talk
I'm on her side if you love someone love
them not your idea of them I don't see
anything wrong with his message he's
being honest this could be a sign that
something is going on wrong going on
with your body that needs medical
attention yeah like eating too much it's
like can we stop blaming this on
diseases if you're fat you're fat it's
because you're fat it's just like
did she dump her or eat him oh here we
go boyfriend Cayenne Safari is a
narcissistic man the at least being
honest while body shaming a woman who
has hormone disorders seems like a red
flag it's better to leave him he is
sugar coating his cruelty it's like
parents saying sweetie I love you but
you're a disappointment well the
question is are you a disappointment
are you a disappointment okay I'll give
you an example guys
when I was in high school
look I did throw a party my parents were
not happy with me they were not it was a
very small one it was like 15 people
yeah and I got caught because I'd always
get caught anything I've ever done I
just get caught and literally my dad
made it very clear that I was a
disappointment and I never did it again
and that's the thing it's like women
have never it's like we go from a young
age of our dads coddling us our mom's
coddling us then the men in our lives
all cuddle us and we go through life
just never having experienced reality
and this is the real red pill we'll go
to work thinking we're doing the same
work that the men do we're not we'll go
to school thinking we're doing better
than the men are we're not we'll go at
home and think we're acting so much
better than the men are and the men are
just stupid we're not and basically the
whole world has just fueled our delusion
yes
and it actually takes a good man who's
not afraid of the crazy system set
against him
to be kind enough to tell us the truth
and this is what she does
this is what she does but I'm sure he'll
be over it he's not really going to be
crying too long about his fat acts
leaving him you know what I mean it's
like you know how women like
it's like us the X's if they don't do
well career-wise you're like whatever
men it's like if they get fat they're
gonna be over you tomorrow I swear they
will not miss you in the slightest if
you're just wailing it they're like I'm
done I'm over it
um okay the next story so Zion
I I don't even watch basketball
but even I have heard of Zion Williamson
he is Apparently one of the best
basketball players in the whole NBA he
he's I don't know freshman of the Year
something whatever they give the
basketball he's gotten some awards I
heard about him when he was in college
and I guess this man gets a lot of women
now I will say
I don't know why it's like if you date a
professional athlete
I don't want to say they're Pro they're
going to cheat on you because there are
athletes that are loyal
but I would say the odds are not in your
favor so if you go for that ladies I
would just be warned you're probably not
the only one
now Zion Zion had some women
like coming out about him giving
accusations and it's funny because they
always accuse the men
that don't need to abuse you that don't
need to Grape you that don't need to do
any of that like it's like these guys
have thrown at them 24 7. like you know
at basketball games there are women that
go run out hotels and try to get the men
to cheat on their wives they literally
they actively
hunt men they literally stalk them on
social media they'll they'll know
everything about these guys run into
them at the event and literally try to
get them to cheat on their wives
and and then they'll say oh but these
these guys are just like abusers it's
like what okay but there's this lady has
an accusation against him let's see
maybe it's probable maybe it sounds real
let's let's pull up the clip you guys I
literally did not want to come to the
internet and I'm just tired of saving
faith for this man that's completely
disrespecting me to the world and I
literally have to take this every time I
come on the internet people are bashing
me because of this man literally and I'm
tired of it he knows he he said he's
gonna send me 62 000 I have yet to
receive that since June I'm literally
here like he's literally a liar
you guys everything he says he's a liar
he's not who he says he is I literally
been saving face I did not want to come
to the world and let you guys know what
he has been doing to me my entire
relationship with him he is a woman
beater and the NBA needs to know this
I literally did not want to come to this
because I know he has so many
endorsements
but Zion Williamson is a woman beater oh
my God and the reason he was paying me
off is so I won't come to the world and
tell everybody
oh my God shut the [__]
you're telling me this guy needs to beat
women
the guy one of the best guys in the NBA
so much so that me who knows nothing
about the NBA knows who he is
you're telling me this guy needs to beat
women
like this [__] is just mad she didn't
get her 62 cat you notice that because
I'm sorry if you really cared about the
truth if you really cared that he beat
women if you really wanted women to be
safe and cared about what was right what
was true you wouldn't accept money to
shut up
and then on top of that this lady is
fake crying like where are the tears if
anybody buys this at the NBA
please send them this video please
because I she's fake crying the only
reason she's coming out is because she
didn't get her 62k like I'm sorry if
somebody beat me you could not pay me to
shut up
and and this lady has a full face of
makeup
I you know if you're just so emotional
and just so hurting about the abuse are
you gonna like beat down your face
full face of mate like it's just this
[__] is so unbelievable yes the
the NBA guys just wake up and think I
need to beat women like it's like all
right
does it happen sure
are there bad men sure but we need to
judge the women that come out and accuse
men just as harshly As we judge the men
for these crimes right now it is guilty
until proven innocent instead of
innocent until proven guilty these these
stories don't make sense you've been
asking him for sixty two thousand
dollars since June
why are you entitled to 62k either he
beat you or he didn't either you want
what's right or or you don't and to me
this idea that you're gonna beat down
your face put on your sunglasses make
sure your nails are done and then go cry
on camera instead of like like this is
the crazy thing she posted on social
media instead of going to the police
why are you on social media instead of
the police because the police will
actually question you and talk about
your story if it doesn't be if it
doesn't match up why don't you go to the
NBA why do you need to expose him why
does everybody need to know why can't we
focus on the facts of the case
but yeah a pretty woman comes on social
media and starts fake not even real
crime that's the worst part
could we at least get some real tears
like if you're gonna do this fake [__]
like could you at least learn how to cry
like
dumbest anyways I don't believe her you
shouldn't believe her and women that
actually want Justice go to the police
they don't go to social media
and I think we should also
famine even for
women on social media that come forward
with screenshots messages because
usually there's another side of the
story that they're not telling
and these feminists will just convince
these women that they're victims and
just give them these words that mean
nothing and just confuse them and like
the women will weaponize the words
against the men
on another episode of women being
perfectly reasonable and really easy to
please as you know women have very low
standards we're super easy to please
we're just just happy go lucky nurturing
kind people so this Uber driver shared a
video of a woman in his car just being
very polite you know us women
Ben yes I am do me a favor can you move
the seat forward because it's hitting my
knees
can you hold on I didn't even put my
seatbelt on sir did you like slow down
you're in a rush because if you're in a
rush I'm gonna panic
[Music]
it's too hot in here can I lower this
window or something yeah go ahead do you
have an air conditioner I prefer the air
conditioner yeah yeah yeah hold on here
you know your seatbelt is really tight
around your neck has anybody else
complained about this no no ma'am well
then take it off no I'm not going to
take it off I'm going to an important
meeting right now like I can't have my
hair meeting at 7 pm what is that your
concern I'm trying to explain to you and
I don't appreciate your smart remark
about me having the meeting at seven
o'clock which I'm gonna be late because
of you sorry about that okay I'm sorry
are you giving me an attitude sir no
ma'am all I have to do is
this app right okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I would just pull over and kick that
[__] out of my car I swear to God that
was so crazy I thought I want I'm like
wondering if that was staged that cannot
be real
I was thinking that too when she said I
have an important meeting I'm like
where's this [__] going like like
dressed like that this doesn't even make
sense
but this is the like this is what
happens when
women just let the resentment like eat
away at them and you see it in wives too
it's like it's like a disease like it
literally just like eats away at them
for years while she's clearly eaten
because she's a big fatty you know so so
clearly she's eaten her emotions are
eating her and now she's just gone crazy
mad and so not only do we have now we're
at the point we get fake false Uber
driver accusations I'm almost to the
point
or instead of believe all women I think
believe no women
now I'm not going to go that far yet
but I think it's sometimes because we
just have this ability to like
exaggerate stories just always be the
victim like
and sometimes I literally think we
believe it like I think we get this like
hysteria about us I don't really get it
but this woman the funny thing too was
she was saying that it was his fault
that she was fat like the seatbelt was
tight because you're fat man get less
fat like I don't know what to tell you I
don't even care like if you want to be a
big fatty but why does everyone else
have to deal with your problem like
women it used to be if you're fat you
had to be pleasant you know what I mean
like that's why it was the nice fatty in
class everyone like she would be very
nice to you because you're fat and you
don't have the looks but she would be
like the kindest sweetest lady and
you're you would never even really bully
or like that but it's like nowadays this
is the level this is the level of chicks
that we're offering you know and then we
get mad at the men for adapting to the
market they're like yeah I don't want a
date this is crazy
and another way another way that they'll
brainwash us is in the music
and this is something that when I really
started listening to the music that
we're singing
it all goes back to egalitarianism and
when I say that I mean equality so this
idea that men and women are equal men
and women are the same women don't need
a man if you trust a man the worst thing
possible is going to happen
um so I see these songs of these like up
and coming artists on Tick Tock and I
think that the music oftentimes reflects
a society and how they think and when I
listen to this song the first thing in
my mind was this is what we have raised
the next generation of women to believe
so pull the clip
if you're having boy problems I feel bad
for you hun I got 99 problems but a dick
game one
okay you don't
need ass [__] no we can't get enough
problems
[Applause]
let's go over some of the lyrics I got
99 problems but it ain't one we can't
even say like what if a guy said I got
99 problems but it ain't one
people would think that's a bit misogyny
this word that they use at me
misogynistic yeah women
can say but uh ain't one but whatever
whatever maybe I'm just being a little
too
you know
misogynistic right that's what I am
another theme of this song is
celebrating being single
they used to shame us for being single
they would call you a leftover woman
um an old maid whatever and basically
they would just bully you until you
found a husband they would be like all
your grandma your mom would be like
what's wrong with you go get a husband
but now they're celebrating being single
but she's young this girl's like 18 19
maybe I mean I'd guess under the age of
25. right we would you think she's over
25 I think she's under 25. so it's like
somebody taught her this some this isn't
like you don't come out
of childhood with all these ideas like
these are new ideas so this is what the
generation of women before us are
teaching us on top of that she says your
man ain't [__] you don't need one now we
have young lost women promoting the
message that you don't need men when
it's so delusional like guys when you
start to think about how delusional this
is men run Society they literally they
run all of the infrastructure of society
there is no job that women can do
without men and on top of that when we
run our own households they go to [__]
they're horrible
even female-led relationships are
horrible we don't like them the men
don't like them but yet yet women will
put in songs that we don't need men this
is a hundred years of propaganda this is
what we are teaching the next generation
of women and it's really really sad but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments am I a misogynist
I'm just so big misogynist big big
misogynist even though I don't pimp out
women on the internet for money
but maybe you know I'm crazy but let me
know in the comments and let me know
what you guys want me to react to next
week subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time